Кіта! До мене!
Щойно Кіта перевірила оператора DW на наявність у нього вибухівки.
Хоч у його руках лише камера, та чотирилапа змалку навчена
таким інспекціям у кінологічному центрі "Антеус"
в Межигір'ї на Київщині. Тут разом із нею живе і тренується
ще кілька десятків собак. Кожна має свою "професію",
корисну як для цивільних, так і для військових.
Приміром, вівчарка Вулкан може наздогнати диверсанта
і вчасно повідомити ЗСУ про підліт безпілотника.
Для такої роботи пса навіть навчили рахувати.
Вулкан, скільки пальців?
А зараз?
А ось так жваво до гостей біжить Петрович.
Цю кавказьку вівчарку кінологи навчили правильно контактувати з людьми
і тим самим проводити з ними каністерапію,
тобто психологічну реабілітацію, для дітей та поранених військових.
На таких тварин, як Петрович, зараз величезний попит.
Петрович! Ой, який слинько! Слинько, ти що!
Він Ваню облизав!
З Петровичем та іншими мешканцями кінологічного центру
сьогодні знайомиться Іван - колишній військовослужбовець, а нині ветеран.
Він буквально наосліп шукає того, хто стане його другом,
охоронцем і головне - професійним поводирем.
Адже чоловік практично повністю втратив зір на фронті -
під час мінометного обстрілу у серпні 2022-го в районі Бахмута,
де обороняв Україну як доброволець ЗСУ.
У мене на правому оці залишилося там сітчатки взагалі кілька,
напевно, міліметрів. І в дуже гарний сонячний день
я можу бачити деяке світло. Але воно не впливає на об'єм картинки.
Ти не бачиш ні силуетів, нічого. Просто світло.
Шансів на відновлення зору в Івана немає.
Чоловіка усюди мусить супроводжувати дружина Влада.
Наша інфраструктура в принципі не пристосована, скажімо так,
взагалі для таких хлопців.
Тому ходити кудись самому, то це дуже-дуже важко.
Ну навіть зрячий може ходити там, спіткнутися об плитку,
яка там роздерта, поломана там.
Сьогодні Іван вперше вийде на прогулянку сам.
А допоможе йому в цьому професійна поводирка,
яку виховали у цьому центрі - вівчарка Діна.
Отак! Привіт! Така чудова собака! Діна! Тримай!
Кінологи центру протягом року готували Діну для таких ветеранів,
як Іван: вона навчена заспокоювати, сигналізувати господарю
про небезпеку і повідомляти про перешкоди, яких він не бачить.
Діна, вперед! Покажи двері!
Молодець! Покажи двері! Ось!
У приміщенні Діна веде ветерана туди, де він може присісти.
Покажи лавку!
Молодець!
Дякую тобі! Молодець! Хороша дівчинка!
Собака настільки показує все чудово. Навіть ті двері, де всі переходи,
сходи, і це дуже класно. І вона тебе береже, щоб ти не впав.
Можеш з нею поспілкуватися, якось навіть стрес знімає, якщо є він.
Він може пересуватися, займатися спортом,
бути більш реалізованим у житті, ніж людина в чотирьох стінах
або така, яка ходить з людиною.
З Діною чоловік проведе лише кілька тренувань,
аби звикнути до собаки в ролі помічника загалом.
Більш доцільно, кажуть кінологи, привчати до конкретної людини
не дорослу собаку, а цуценя.
Його ветерану підберуть кінологи і навчать бути
індивідуальним супутником саме для Івана.
Собака-поводир готується протягом року.
Достатньо довгий час, після чого ми кличемо сюди Ваню.
Він з нами якийсь час живе тут, тому що дуже важливо,
щоб і вранці він вставав, і біля нього була собака -
ми бачили це правильно, як собака реагує на нього.
Щоб виходив з нею на вулицю - ми це бачили все на наші очі.
І тоді ми зможемо його спокійно відпустити додому.
У кінологічного центру "Антеус" - цікава історія.
У 2014-му це був центр підготовки собак виключно
для охорони українського президента-втікача Віктора Януковича.
Тибетський мастиф Інна ще застала тодішнього "господаря".
Кінолог пан Петро почав виховувати її тоді ще цуценям.
Це єдине місце, куди Янукович приїздив без охорони.
Міг приїхати кілька разів на день.
Настільки він любив собак.
В олігархів вічні стреси: мільярдик вкрадуть,
вб'ють завтра, "кидонуть" як лоха.
Як стреси знімати?
Пан Петро розповідає: після втечі Януковича цю територію досі
не вдалося офіційно оформити у розпорядження центру.
Стабільного фінансування теж немає: собак спершу
утримували за рахунок самих кінологів.
Згодом витрати покривали коштом екскурсій
у парк "Межигір'я" для туристів.
У 2014-му у центр почали зверталися військові -
за чотирилапими розвідниками, саперами та охоронцями.
Кінологи ретельно відбирають цуценят, щоденно тренують їх
та вже дорослими безкоштовно передають ЗСУ.
Нині на виховання однієї службової собаки, собаки-поводиря
чи тварини для терапії потрібно не менше двохсот тисяч гривень на рік.
А оскільки в Україні не існує комплексної державної програми
з підготовки таких тварин, офіційну сертифікацію вихованці
можуть отримати виключно за кордоном, найближче - у Польщі.
Для цього кінологам доводиться спеціально вивозити собак на іспити,
а це затягує процес їх підготовки і створює додаткові витрати.
У подібних кінологічних центрах в Європі виховання таких службових тварин
майже повністю оплачує держава.
Десь в іншій країні - за 30 тисяч доларів. Ви не знайдете дешевшу.
І всі вони державні! І всі вони з документами!
А в нас нема законодавчої бази.
Однак після 24 лютого 2022 року кінологічний центр "Антеус"
опинився під загрозою закриття.
У перші тижні вторгнення РФ частина працівників пішла служити в ЗСУ.
Центр уже двічі потрапляв під ракетний обстріл,
через це двічі горіли його приміщення.
Дивом і люди, і собаки тут вціліли.
Зараз наслідки пожеж прикрили фанерними дошками на вікнах і стінах.
А навпроти вольєрів тут поставили загородження,
щоб уламки ракет від нових прильотів не зачепили чотирилапих.
Знайти стабільне фінансування на відновлення ушкоджених
приміщень і на утримання собак у центрі наразі неможливо.
Платні екскурсії у парку "Межигір'я" нині не проводять,
а волонтери не можуть допомагати регулярно.
У нас просто формат виживання.
Харчування частково була змога, знайшли і закупили.
Просили організації, волонтерів, які можуть допомагати кормами.
Щось привозять, щось дістаємо.
Тобто це вже не за фінанси, а більше за дружні зв'язки, знайомства.
Ми працюємо за ідею! Ми працюємо за те, щоб наше напрацювання
приносило користь суспільству. Не чиновникам, не політикам.
Допомогти знайти кошти для потреб центру запропонував
один з українських ветеранів, який колись сам прийшов сюди
обрати собі собаку-поводиря. Владислав Єщенко теж втратив зір
на фронті, як і Іван, якого він, власне, і привів сюди.
Разом ветерани хочуть підтримати заклад збором коштів
від небайдужих українців, а ще - достукатися до меценатів
за кордоном, які допомогли б "Антеусу" пережити воєнні часи.
Це об'єднана ідея інформаційної і фінансової кампанії.
Як в ідеалі це має виглядати? Ми розповідаємо інформацію,
які зараз є потреби у кінологічного центру.
Наступний етап - ми намагаємося розповісти про те, що можна
проводити благодійні екскурсії в кінологічний центр для того,
щоб люди могли приїхати сюди познайомитися з собачками,
які тут є, побачити наскільки це важливо і актуально,
подивитися, які є потреби, і щоб мали можливість задонатити.
Після втрати зору я був настільки шокований,
що триває війна, а в нас жодної програми на рівні держави
не було створено. Це зараз якісь проєкти розвитку цього напрямку.
У самій державі, я думаю, це не так важко було би зробити.
Просто в нас цим не хочуть займатися.
Бо краще ж вкрасти, ніж дати на розвиток.
Тим часом у цьому кінологічному центрі за вихованцями продовжують
буквально стояти в черзі не лише поранені ветерани, а й цивільні,
які постраждали від воєнної агресії РФ.
Тутешні кінологи переконують: якби забезпечити такому закладу
стабільне фінансування, тут могли би навчати
значно більше чотирилапих помічників.